sur les étagères les produits de
première nécessité sont pris d'assaut et
les rayons des valises et l'épicerie
sociale de la croix-rouge d'elancourt
créé en 2011 tente de faire face à
l'afflux massif récent de demandeurs
d'asile près de 70 familles adressées
par les centres communaux d'action
sociale
une population qui s'ajoutent aux
habitués des familles des personnes
seules il ya beaucoup de personnes au
chômage des personnes des retraités de
plus en plus pour pas oublier les
personnes en retraite connaissent aussi
de beaucoup de difficultés pour payer
leurs charges hors loyers en juillet
dernier l'épicerie sociale se munit
d'une chambre froide indispensable pour
l'apport en fruits et légumes frais de
plus en plus il ya beaucoup de monde qui
sont dans les secours populaire comme le
va tout ce qui est
alimentation donc je vois que les gens
c'est de plus en plus difficile pour
tout le monde quoi un sentiment partagé
par les bénévoles du relais d'elancourt
qui estime toutefois que le nombre de
bénéficiaires inscrits n'est pas le
reflet de la réalité je pense qu'on a
quand même beaucoup qui ne viennent pas
encore linos pas venir parce que c'est
pas évident du tout pour de faire la
démarche d'aller voir un travailleur
social et de faire la démarche de venir
ici c'est c'est une difficulté qu'il
faut surmonter en 2012 305 nouvelles
familles ont franchi les portes des
l'épicerie sociale